[Musique]
c'est un concept qui vient des Pays-Bas
la salle snowsen il s'agit d'un espace
qui permet de stimuler les 5 sens Louis
avec la musique la vue avec les
différentes lumières ou encore le
toucher avec des multiples objets sable
cailloux coussin dans le département une
salle snozyveline vient d'ouvrir ses
portes c'est la première en France qui
s'étend à tous les publics on a voulu
donc un espace ouvert sur la ville et
surtout de la prévention de ne pas
attendre que la personne soit
complètement grabataire qu'elle rentre
en institution pour bénéficier d'un
espace bien-être mais pourquoi ne pas
ouvrir un espace bien-être vers la ville
donc et puis donc c'est un espace qui
est ouvert que ça soit aux institutions
aux EHPAD à aux hôpitaux aux
institutions médicaux psychologiques ou
ime etc qui s'occupent des enfants ou
des crèches leur offrir cet espace là
d'apaisement
et de bien-être et en fait prévenir un
petit peu l'autonomie de la personne
avant qu'elle arrive à qu'elle arrive
vraiment à l'hôpital ou en institution
l'objectif ils sont multiples mais le
but est principalement de détendre les
personnes atteintes de troubles
psychiques et cet après-midi c'est
Marie-Thérèse de guerre qu'une dame âgée
de 89 ans atteinte de la maladie
d'Alzheimer qui teste pour la première
fois la salle snows Yvelines
avec mon père surtout
il se met tout ça puis moi je binais
pour tirer tous les petits poussins dans
les rayons
très bien ça vous rappelle votre jardin
et ça
couché vous pouvez
de la farine la farine après avoir testé
plusieurs objets l'octogénaire a
également pu essayer le matelas à eau un
moment de calme et d'apaisement
[Musique]
bilan de la séance pour la
psychomotricienne il s'agit d'une bonne
première pour Marie-Thérèse elle a
notamment pu faire appel à des souvenirs
lointains au terme de la réminiscence
des souvenirs qui étaient heureux pour
le coup son jardin
si elle a si elle avait pu avoir des
animaux également de de compagnie ça
permet en fait de stimuler les les
fonctions cognitives de façon indirecte
en passant justement par les sens cet
espace de détente est situé dans
l'ancien collège Paul Cézanne de
Mantes-la-Jolie aujourd'hui devenu le
campus départemental Cézanne imaginé par
l'association Athéna formation elle
propose également un fauteuil relaxant
un espace avec des huiles essentielles
mais aussi une douche sensorielle avec
des fibres optiques
[Musique]